[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous l'invité de
la nouvelle formule de saint roch a dit
à l'occasion du fort dit des municipales
nous allons recevoir bertrand qu'abréger
mois en alternance les candidats aux
élections de 2010 20 chaque candidat
aura cinq minutes pour s'exprimer
donc l'invité ce matin c'est elie car
unique vous êtes membre du mode et
martinique bonjour aux jambes et vous
êtes candidat 15 pilotes vous allez
conduire la liste 15 pilotes un
mouvement cette année a en effet alors
pourquoi vous présentez monsieur
carbonique ma présente ma candidature
est légitime parce que depuis à la joute
conséquent je me suis mis au service de
ma commune j'ai été élu maire adjoint ça
fait deux fois que la population m'a
permis d'être les minorités donc dans la
majorité dans l'accession
le conseil municipal accueille dans les
minorités et que j'estime que ça qu'ils
soient passés au juliaca ce lot est
inacceptable qu'est ce qui se passe à 4
cyl peau qu'est ce qui se passe pourquoi
vous avez l'air si remonté j'ai là j'ai
parlé je suis très remonté par rapport à
la situation financière de la ville et
les causes c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
nous avons un maire qui décide et sa
majorité valide
nous avons un maire c'est ça que ça se
passe d'habitude que la majorité
participer valide aussi un peu les
orientations c'est un peu ce qui se
passe dans toutes les mairies non je
crois je crois que le maire est là pour
exécuter les décisions du conseil non le
contraire donc aujourd'hui aussi
impulser il peut impulser mais tant
qu'il n'a pas présenté
l'impulsion dont vous parlez au conseil
municipal
il ne peut pas prendre des décisions
comme si qasmi leur appartient est ce
que fait monsieur mon plaisir
aujourd'hui c'est ce que nous constatons
c'est ce que nous constatons avec un gel
des plans et jeudi qu' aujourd'hui si
nous sommes dans cette situation là
c'est que le maire d'agde à ce pilote à
privilégier l'intérêt personnel audit
de l'intérêt général qui les délits de
favoritisme et prise illégale d'intérêt
vous avez des preuves qu'on vous dit
j'ai des points monsieur j'ai des
preuves je peux ne suffit pas de dire et
puis de se faire condamner pour
diffamation
mais est-ce que vous avez des preuves
qu'elle creva des gens je vous conseille
vivement de dôme a dit au maire de
cazouls lot de me poser en diffamation
je mettrai l'épreuve à disposition tous
les piloter puisque j'ai au rapport de
fonctionnaires de la direction la
répression des fraudes car c est le
procureur sur la base de leur carte et
je pensais que la justice allait faire
son travail
aujourd'hui il me semble que rien n'a
été fait donc il ya matière à revoir les
choses pour kaka sur lot puissent
bénéficier de l'argent qu'elle a perdu
et a perdu beaucoup d'argent dans cette
affaire
d'accord de quelle affaire vous parle
exactement par les marchés publics
concernant les communes à l'heure de la
ville dont le maire a présidé les comme
seul appel d'offres et il a favorisé
qu'avec moteur jeu j'ai tous les
éléments qu'il a permis de redire pour
vous citer un exemple une opération kkr
moteur a répondu à 541 me l'euro se sent
qu'avec moderne a pas eu le manche et
une autre entreprise a eu le marché à
704 71 1000 euros et ce soit même marché
vous vous exposez vraiment des
poursuites donc jeunes va peut-être
passer à autre chose je n'ai pas
d'autres poursuites je dis ce qu'il en
est et sur ce même marché dans le merapi
l'intégralité du marché il a donné à
quatre moteurs ans bolt a man 2 80 euros
sur cette même opération
donc je dis tout ça ça mérite d'être
regardé attentivement la commune les
piloter auprès de l'argent il faudrait
un moment donné km à la commune ça qu'il
a profité quelles sont les grandes
lignes de votre programme
monsieur car unique mon programme si je
vous dis il faut quasiment pour
consulter ce qui a été démoli c'est à
dire cet avion aujourd'hui à cassis lot
il n'y a pas de développement culturel
il n'y a pas de développement sportif
il n'y a pas de politique sociale
aujourd'hui ce qu'on nous a promis à 12
ans il n'y a pas de développement
économique
la situation fait que chacun se regarde
en chiens de faïence
il y à une pauvreté qui s'installe est
due aux augmentations dépôt donc je dis
qu'il faut reconstruire tout sur tout ce
qui pour les piloter à vincent c'est à
dire la fête patronale de la ville qui a
été détruit c'est aujourd'hui c'est une
fête de quartier jeudi que tout était à
refaire
mais pour la faire il faudrait d'abord
que nous faisons un plan de redressement
de la ville pour permettre à la ville de
retrouver sa capacité d'investissement
et c'est à ce moment là que nous pouvons
apporter des réponses claires nettes et
précises à la population notamment ceux
qui attendront les routes de citronnelle
ceux qui attendraient ou de nicolo
certaines personnes qui sont venues
habiter à case-pilote on leur a donné
aucune possibilité d'être accueilli dans
les bonnes conditions et c'est pourquoi
je dis que tout est offert
merci et l'icc haroon unique bonne
journée aller coûte de nos programmes